hey guys I am at peace of Toronto today
which is Toronto's hottest food event
I'm actually hosting one of the stages
all weekend long so in between sessions
I'm going to get to eat lots of good
things so let's do this I was on a
mission to find all the best food and
honestly I didn't have to look very hard
because everything looked amazing little
treat so I was craving some protein and
they had an amazing barbecue set up over
there so some little beautiful trees of
sausage and the chicken is watering so I
can barely talk right now so I'm gonna
dig right in
just melting out
[Music]
[Music]
videos so audio sides will obviously add
to get myself a popsicle and this is a
beautiful fresh made peach lemonade pop
logo food events should never be about
counting calories but I think we had a
lot of friends around all weekend help
me sample all these yummy things that I
didn't fill up too quickly especially
before dessert
[Music]
okay so one of my favorite restaurants
in the city was making these amazing for
cheddar sandwiches and I could not
reserve honestly I may not hear all the
bread because it is out of that but I'm
pretty excited about the meat probe oh
okay so I'm going to eat all the bread
because it's really good bread okay so I
wasn't just there for the food I was
working on my feet from morning till
night so I was working up a serious
appetite over to chef David Lee here um
no to that all right so it's the middle
of the day and I need my coffee fixed
and they have free coffee so I'm pretty
happy about that
oh my god I was craving vegetables at
this point honestly I love sampling mac
and cheese and meaty sandwiches and
things but I have to listen to my body
and my body needs veg
[Music]
well it would not be a day at a food
event without some ice cream and look
how beautiful that is
it's a organic vanilla frozen yogurt
with some beautiful strawberry rhubarb
sauce and basil supervisor not so Roker
all right so we haven't exactly had set
meal times here I've kind of just been
grazing all day long as I've been
working away but I get this officially
dinnertime so I'm going to go get
slimming eat all right so I have waited
all day because I've been so excited
about this it's my favorite burger in
the world it is the best there's like a
beet relish on top and like the most
perfect cheese and it's just like some
amazing fun I'm going to dig in right
now
my happy place for her
[Music]
so I need a little pick-me-up a little
late-night snack here so I got a little
bow which is like literally my favorite
food group so I'm excited about this
[Music]
so sloppy rubbish
alright I have finally done for the day
but I promised myself a little donut
treat which I'm super excited about
oh my gosh so guys a little pistachio
cream in there hmm
this is my jam alright
yes yes yes yes so guys I had an awesome
time at Kate's of Toronto I am soaking
wet is really really calming down right
now but some nice person gave me the
free Java so I'm in a good spirit I'm
super well fed I'm feeling good well
guys I hope you enjoyed my little what I
eat in a day at the successful if you
did be sure to give this video a thumbs
up leave me a comment below and of
course subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's good side
[Music]
you